ya he hecho bastantes vídeos de la
respiración creo que incluso antes de
esos vídeos sabías que
si ta vos
sí
y de qué
miramos
2 y si viste los vídeos de respiración
sabrás que necesitamos del oxígeno para
poder metabolizar nuestra comida para
poder convertir nuestra comida en atp es
que entonces pueden conducir a otros
tipos de funciones celulares o cualquier
actividad que tengamos que hacer
movernos o respirar o pensar o cualquier
actividad que tengamos que hacer y que a
través del proceso de respiración
descomponemos esos azúcares y liberamos
dióxido de carbono así que en este vídeo
lo que quiero hacer es regresar un gran
paso atrás y pensar en como nosotros
llevamos el oxígeno adentro de nuestro
cuerpo y cómo lo liberamos nuevamente a
la atmósfera otra manera en la que
podemos pensar en eso es en cómo nos
ventilamos en la bne
y la acción
como ingresamos el oxígeno y como
llevamos el dióxido de carbono afuera y
creo que cualquiera de nosotros podría
al menos empezar este vídeo la
ventilación empieza tanto en nuestra
nariz como en nuestra boca y siempre he
tenido los senos paranasales obstruidos
así que frecuentemente tengo que
utilizar mi boca solo dormir con la boca
abierta pero siempre empieza en nuestra
nariz o en nuestra boca déjame dibujar a
alguien con una nariz
y una poca digamos que esta es nuestra
persona este es mi sujeto
dibujaré su boca abierta para que pueda
respirar sus ojos no son importantes
pero los dibujos para que sepas que es
una persona así que este es mi sujeto de
estudio
o la persona que utilizaré para hacer el
diagrama esta es su oreja quizá él tiene
un poco de pongámosle un poco de cabello
todo eso es relevante y lo importante es
que es nuestro sujeto este es el que nos
mostrará como ingresamos el aire y como
llevamos el aire afuera de nuestro
cuerpo así que vayamos al interior de
este sujeto puedo dibujar su exterior
primero déjame ver como bueno veamos
cómo puedo hacer esto esta es la parte
exterior del sujeto esto no se ve bien
digamos que el sujeto se ve algo así y
estos son sus hombros
este es nuestro sujeto bien así que en
nuestra boca tenemos nuestra cavidad
oral justo ahí la cual es solo el
espacio que nuestra boca crea tenemos
nuestra cavidad oral podemos dibujar
nuestra lengua que es algo así
pero tienes este espacio dentro de la
boca lo llamamos cavidad oral este
espacio adentro de la boca justo aquí
esta es la cavidad
oral por boca cavidad por espacio o
agujero o apertura y también tiene sus
fosas nasales y ellas desembocan en la
cavidad nasal desembocan en la cavidad
nasal así que este es otro espacio
grande justo como éste
y sabemos que se conectan en la parte
trasera de la nariz o de nuestra boca y
este pasaje justo aquí donde se conectan
se llama
cuando el aire va a través de tu nariz y
dicen que respirar a través de tu nariz
es mejor probablemente porque el aire se
filtra por vellos nasales y se calienta
pero puede respirar tanto por la boca
como por la nariz el aire ingresa por tu
cavidad nasal o por tu cavidad oral y
luego pasa a través de tu faringe
más adelante la faringe se divide en dos
ductos uno para bueno el aire puede
bajar por cualquiera de los dos pero el
otro es únicamente para comida así que
tu faringe se divide en la parte
posterior tienes a tu esófago y
hablaremos más del esófago en el futuro
vídeo
déjame dibujar una pequeña línea
divisora ahí
en la parte delantera se divide justo
así
atrás de producto de aire tienes tu
esófago déjame hacer eso en otro color y
esto de aquí es tú
soy
y esto de aquí estuvo la
green
el esófago es por donde baja la comida
sabemos que comemos la comida con
nuestra boca también por aquí es por
donde queremos que pase nuestra comida
que atraviese el esófago este ducto es
para
da
pero en este vídeo nos enfocaremos en la
ventilación qué hacemos con nuestro aire
así que me enfocaré en como el aire
atraviesa nuestra laringe y la laringe
es también nuestra caja de voz mientras
me escuchas a hablar están estas
pequeñas cuerdas vibrando a las
frecuencias adecuadas y puedo darle la
forma al sonido con mi boca para hacer
este vídeo así que esta también es tu
caja de sonidos pero no me enfocaré en
esto ahora se llama caja de voz debido a
toda esta estructura anatómica que se ve
algo así pero después de que el aire
pasa a través de la laringe esta es la
vía de ingreso va hacia la tráquea la
cual es esencialmente solo el ducto de
aire el esófago es el ducto para la
comida déjame escribir esto esta es
nuestra
qué
y luego desde la tráquea y la tráquea es
de hecho una estructura rígidamente
razonable tiene cartílago alrededor y
tiene sentido de que tenga cartílago
puedes imaginar una manguera si se dobla
mucho no podría pasar mucha agua por
ella o mucho aire a través de ella así
que no quieres que esto se doble mucho
esa es la razón por la cual requiere
tener más rigidez por eso debe tener
cartílago alrededor y luego se divide en
dos ductos
y creo que sabes a dónde se dirigen esos
dos ductos y no estoy dibujando esto con
muchos detalles solo quiero que
entiendas la idea de ellos pero estos
dos ductos son los bronquios o cada uno
es un bronquio estos son los
dios
y también tienen cartílago así que son
lo suficientemente rígidos y después los
bronquios siguen dividiéndose
siguen dividiéndose en ductos más y más
pequeños justo así y en algún punto
dejan de tener cartílago dejaron de ser
razonablemente rígidos pero siguen
dividiéndose así que sólo los dibujaré
como líneas delicadas
en un punto se convierten en ductos muy
pequeños sólo siguen dividiéndose así
que el aire sólo sigue dividiéndose y se
esparce y baja a través de las distintas
partes y cuando los bronquios ya no
tienen cartílagos alrededor de ellos ya
no son rígidos los primeros de ellos se
llaman o de hecho todos los ductos
después de ese punto son llamados
bronquiolos este es un dron
yo
son solo ductos que se hacen cada vez
más delgados
hemos etiquetado las diferentes partes
de los ductos con diferentes nombres
pero la idea es que empiece desde
nuestra boca o nuestra nariz y solo
sigamos dividiendo y dividiendo está
división principal en dos ductos
diferentes que nos llevan a cada uno de
nuestros pulmones déjame dibujar los
pulmones de este sujeto aquí este es uno
de los pulmones de este sujeto y este es
el otro pulmón los bronquios se dividen
en pulmones y los bronquiolos están en
los pulmones eventualmente los bronquios
se acaban y aquí es donde se vuelve
interesante se siguen dividiendo cada
vez más en ductos más delgados y más
delgados hasta desembocar en estas
pequeñas bolsas de aire justo así
al final de cada pequeño bronquiolos
están estas bolsas de aire bolsas de
aire diminutas justo así
y hablaré de estas bolsas de aire en un
segundo estas se llaman 'la
ve
los
he utilizado muchas de las palabras
sofisticadas pero la idea general es
simple el aire ingresa a través del
ducto el ducto se hace cada vez más
delgado y acaba en estas pequeñas bolsas
de aire y de seguro te preguntas bueno
cómo es que eso lleva el oxígeno dentro
de mi sistema y bien la clave aquí es
que estas bolsas de aire son diminutas y
tienen paredes muy muy delgadas o
imagino que membranas delgadas así que
déjame ampliar la imagen si fuéramos a
hacer un acercamiento a uno de estos
alveolos y solo para darte una idea
estos son muy muy muy pequeños los he
dibujado lo suficientemente grandes aquí
pero cada alvéolo déjame dibujarlos un
poco más grandes déjame dibujar estas
bolsas de aire tienes estas bolsas de
aire así y luego tienes un bronquio lo
que termina en la bolsa de aire tal vez
un bronquio lo está
terminando en otra bolsa de aire justo
así en otro grupo de bolsas de aire
justo así cada una de estas tiene solo
de 200 a 300 micras de diámetro así que
esa distancia justo es d
200 a 300
micras
y en caso que no sepas que es una migra
una micra es una millonésima de un metro
o puedes verlo como una milésima de
milímetro así que estas son 200
milésimas de milímetro o puedes pensar
en ellas como y esta es de hecho una
manera muy fácil de visualizarlo esto es
alrededor de un quinto d
milímetro
si de hecho intentó dibujar esto en una
pantalla si tú haces esto en pantalla
completa un milímetro es aproximadamente
esa distancia así que imagina un quinto
de eso y eso es a lo que nos referimos
como el diámetro de una de estas y solo
para ponerlo en el esquema completo
relativo a las células la célula
promedio en el cuerpo humano es de
alrededor de 10 micras así que esto es
sólo alrededor de 20 ó 30 células en
diámetro o relativo a la célula promedio
en el cuerpo humano esto tiene una
membrana muy delgada si los ves como
globos el globo es muy delgado casi como
el espesor de una célula y están
conectados con el flujo sanguíneo o de
hecho una mejor manera de pensar en eso
es que nuestro sistema circulatorio pasa
justo al lado de cada uno de estos tiene
vasos sanguíneos que vienen del corazón
y que quieren ser oxigenados en general
los vasos sanguíneos que no tienen
y haré esto con muchos más detalles
cuando hagan los vídeos del corazón y
nuestro sistema circulatorio los vasos
sanguíneos que no tienen oxígeno la
sangre de 'shock' sijena da es un poco
más obscura se ve un poco púrpura así
que la dibujaré a azul estos son pasos
que vienen del corazón esta sangre de
aquí no tiene oxígeno en ella o está
haciendo de eso oxigenada o tiene muy
poco oxígeno en ella y el nombre para
los vasos sanguíneos que vienen del
corazón es arterias déjame escribir eso
repasar eso nuevamente cuando lo veamos
en el corazón así que
días
los sanguíneos
pero sí
mientes
de él
con la sol
de seguro has escuchado de las arterias
los vasos que van al corazón se llaman
más
las venas
ansia
con razón
es muy importante tener eso en cuenta
porque después verás que las arterias no
siempre cargan oxígeno o no están
siempre des oxigenadas y las venas no
siempre tienen una dirección o la otra
entraremos en más detalles cuando
hablemos del corazón y el sistema
circulatorio pero recuerda las arterias
se alejan las venas se dirigen al
corazón
estas son arterias alejándose del
corazón a los pulmones a los alveolos
porque quieren que la sangre que viaja
en ellas tome oxígeno lo que sucederá es
que el aire fluye a través de los
bronquiolos y circulará alrededor de los
alveolos llenando a los alveolos y
mientras llena a los alveolos a las
pequeñas moléculas de oxígeno se les
permite cruzar la membrana de los
alveolos y esencialmente ser absorbidas
a la sangre
hablaremos mucho más de eso cuando
hablemos de la hemoglobina y glóbulos
rojos pero solo tienes que tomar en
cuenta que hay muchos capilares los
capilares son vasos sanguíneos diminutos
que permiten que el aire para ser
esencialmente oxígeno y moléculas de
dióxido de carbono para pasar entre
ellos estos tienen muchos capilares en
ellos que permiten el intercambio de
gases el oxígeno puede ingresar a esta
sangre y entonces una vez que el oxígeno
este es el vaso que viene del corazón y
luego es solo un ducto después de que
obtenga oxígeno regresará al corazón
pasará lo mismo con estas dos y
esencialmente ese es el punto donde este
vaso este ducto parte de nuestro sistema
circulatorio cambia de ser una arteria
porque viene del corazón a una vena
porque regresa al corazón y hay una
palabra especial para estas arterias y
venas se llaman pulmonares así que
alejándose del corazón a los pulmones a
los alveolos estas son las
días
pool
volviendo al corazón están las venas
nada 3 ahora estarás diciendo y que
significa pulmonar bueno pulmo viene del
latín para pulmones literalmente
significa las arterias que son de los
pulmones o que van a los pulmones y las
venas que vienen de los pulmones todas
las veces que la gente habla de
cualquier cosa pulmonar hablan de
nuestros pulmones o quizá algo
relacionado a cómo respiramos es bueno
conocer esta palabra de todas maneras
tienes tu oxigeno entrando por tu boca o
tu nariz a través de la faringe puede
llenar tu estómago podemos inflar
nuestro estómago como un globo pero eso
no nos ayuda de hecho a llevar oxígeno a
nuestro flujo sanguíneo el oxígeno
pasará a través de nuestra laringe a
nuestra tráquea a través de los
bronquios eventualmente en los
bronquiolos acabando en los alvéolos y
siendo capaces de ser absorbidos
que eran las arterias pero luego
regresaremos y esencialmente oxygen
haremos la sangre los glóbulos rojos se
tornan rojos una vez que la hemoglobina
se torna muy roja o escarlata una vez
que tiene el oxígeno y luego regresamos
pero al mismo tiempo esto no es sólo de
introducir oxígeno en nuestras arterias
o en la hemoglobina es también de
liberar dióxido de carbono estas
arterias azules viniendo de los pulmones
también van a liberar dióxido de carbono
en los alveolos y esto será exhalado así
que tenemos oxígeno entrando entra
los otros elementos estarán entrando
pero el o2 es lo que es absorbido en los
alveolos y luego cuando exhalamos
tendremos dióxido de carbono que estaba
en nuestra sangre pero luego es
absorbido en los alveolos y son
exprimidos te diré en un segundo como
son exprimidos se saca dióxido de
carbono es de hecho el sacar el aire lo
que hace vibrar las cuerdas vocales y me
permite hablar pero no entraré en
detalles en eso la última cosa que hay
que considerar de todo este sistema
respiratorio o de nuestros pulmones es
como fuerza al aire adentro y como
fuerza al aire afuera y la manera en la
que lo hace realmente como podrías
imaginar un tipo de bomba o globo
tenemos esta gran capa de músculos
planos déjame escoger un buen color aquí
justo abajo de los pulmones tenemos esta
gran capa de músculos planos
y esto es llamado día
más
ahora chico
y entonces cuando está relajado tiene
esta forma de arco y entonces los
pulmones se contraen no tienen mucho
volumen pero cuando yo esencialmente
inhaló lo que pasa es que este diafragma
torácico se contrae y cuando está
contraído se vuelve más pequeño pero más
importante abre el espacio donde están
mis pulmones así que mis pulmones pueden
llenar ese espacio lo que hace
esencialmente es es como agrandar un
globo hacer el volumen de mis pulmones
mayor y cuando haces el volumen de algo
mayor para que los pulmones se agranden
mientras mi vía fragma torácico se
contrae y se arquea hacia abajo y haga
más espacio y mientras el volumen de
algo se hace más grande la presión en el
interior de ellos disminuye si recuerdas
de física la presión por el volumen es
una constante así que cuando
inhalamos
hablamos nuestro cerebro está
esencialmente diciéndole a nuestro
diafragma que se contraiga el día
más
tenemos más espacio alrededor de
nuestros pulmones nuestros pulmones
pulmones
para llenar el espacio tenemos menos
presión aquí que la que tenemos afuera
la puedes ver como presión negativa el
aire siempre quiere ir de presión alta a
presión baja y entonces el aire entrará
en nuestros pulmones y ojalá haya algo
de oxígeno allí que pueda entonces
esencialmente entrar en nuestros
alveolos y acabar en nuestras arterias y
luego regresar a las venas como oxígeno
unido a la hemoglobina hablaré más de
eso en detalle y luego cuando paremos de
contraer el diafragma vuelve a esta
posición arqueada se contrae es como una
liga de hule contrae los pulmones y
esencialmente saca el aire de regreso y
ahora ese aire tendrá mucho más dióxido
de carbono y solo para darnos una idea
puedo ver mis pulmones bueno no puedo
verlos pero no se ven tan grandes
cómo puedo meter suficiente oxígeno en
ellos y la clave es es que debido a este
proceso de ramificación y a los alveolos
la superficie interior de los pulmones
es de hecho mucho mayor de lo que puedas
imaginar o de hecho de lo que podría
imaginar que alguien no me dijera así
que de hecho resulta y lo investigue la
superficie interna de tus alveolos el
área superficial total donde el oxígeno
puede absorberse o el dióxido de carbono
puede ser expulsado de la sangre es de
hecho de 75 metros cuadrados
esos son metros no pies metros cuadrados
si piensas en ello es como imagina un
tipo de campo que sea casi de 9 x 9
metros ese es el tamaño del patio
trasero de algunas personas
eso es cuánta área superficial de aire
tienes dentro de tus pulmones está toda
doblada así es como está acomodada en
los que se ven relativamente como
pulmones pequeños pero eso es lo que nos
da el área superficial suficiente para
aire y suficiente oxígeno para cruzar la
membrana de los alveolos para llegar al
sistema circulatorio y suficiente
dióxido de carbono para regresarlo y
solo para darnos una idea de cuántos
alveolos tenemos te dije que son muy
pequeños de hecho tenemos 300 millones
en cada pulmón en cada pulmón tenemos
300 millones de albiol los de todas
maneras ojalá eso te dé un sentido
decente de como nosotros por lo menos
agregamos oxígeno
nuestro sistema circulatorio y llevamos
dióxido de carbono fuera de él en el
siguiente vídeo hablaré más de nuestro
sistema circulatorio actual de cómo
llevamos el oxígeno de los pulmones al
resto del cuerpo y cómo obtenemos el
dióxido de carbono del resto del cuerpo
a los pulmones